so I just wanted to get your
understanding what theil is and see if
we can talk about that what the uh theil
what like what is
theil what is the yes Allah subhah waala
in the Holy Quran chapter
three chapter 3 verse uh two Allah says
what's your name Avery
a Avery Avery yes you coming from where
where are you from I'm from the
US all right I'm from Kenya but I'm inam
for a very big debate oh box and then we
will let me answer first the question a
very humble man that is you see you
don't have to make arguments uh what the
Quran says he wants another inter
interpretation
from different
people the Quran here says this is
Chapter 3 of the Holy
Quran chapter 3 we reading verse two
Allah
says it is he who has sent down the book
this Quran he Allah God the creator of
the heavens and the
Earth
and none has the right to be worship
except God and he
is he's the ever living one the one who
sustains and protects all that exists
that is Allah the one that we believe it
is he who has sent down the book The
Quran to you Muhammad with truth so this
Quran has been brought down to Muhammad
sallahu alaihi wasall as a prophet of
Allah to Mankind in
truth and it is him Allah who sent the
Torah
Torah is the laws that were given to
Moses inil is a Hebrew word if you say
in English in in Greek they call it
gospel you ask me what is theel inil is
a Hebrew word in English they call it
the good news you see in Greek they call
it the
gospel in Hebrew they call it
the I
think yeah so so um I've actually heard
that the word in Gio like you said like
in the Greek it's the gospel it comes
from the word e like Evangelion which is
like Evangelion or in that it derives
from the Greek right um a lot a lot of
times Muslims that I that I talk to they
say that we don't have the gospel today
like Matthew Mark Luke and John is not
the gospel that was in existence in U
Muhammad's time and so I find I find
trouble with that because the Quran
doesn't seem to say that it says that it
confirms what's with the Christians
right the gospel that's with them in
Muhammad's time which would have been
Matthew Mark Luke and John so what are
your thoughts on that uh I can't give
you my thoughts I can think I can give
you the verse the Quran did not say that
we if is confirming what is with the
Christians no listen what the Quran says
chter 12 ver
108 Allah
says Allah says uh chapter 12 that
is verse
111 Allah
says surely indeed the stories that
you're giving here is a lesson for men
of understanding this
Quran it's the Quran is not a f
statement Quran is not a fge statement
Quran is the word of
God but a confirmation of Allah's
existing
books a confirmation of God's existing
books the Torah the zabur the inil and
see other books that were given to other
prophets you get my point my brother
Allah says it is the confirmation of the
existing book which were
before the inil the gospel yeah the
Torah that is the law
mhm the Psalms that is the Zab
of so as Muslims we believe in all these
prophets but our question
comes where are these
books because
that you have now the ones that you have
now is not the books that God had
revealed to Jesus or Moses right that's
that's what I that's what I usually hear
and so I'm glad that you're using the
Quran so uh verses that pop up to me it
are if you could just check chapter 4:
47 it says yes sir yes sir it says that
talk about Quran 447 talks about the
Sabbath
right it it says that um that if that
they are supposed to believe in what God
has sent down confirming what is with
them all you who have been given the
scripture you have been given the
scripture the Jews and the Christians
believe in what we have revealed to you
you have to believe in what has been
revealed to you right yes believe in
also what have been revealed to Muhammad
sallahu alaihi wasallam the verse is
here
if you believe in the inil if you
believe in the Torah if you believe in
those books then you must believe in
what has been revealed to Muhammad if
you want to believe in this verse that
that is the message of the Quran yes yes
you see now I think you can get message
of the Quran thank you very much
secondly Allah
says we have revealed to you Muhammad
confirming what is already with you what
is already with him muhamad
that is the no he's he's still talking
he's still talking to the people of the
scripture he's he's telling them that
they have to believe in the Quran which
confirms what is already with them right
there the Torah the gospel the zabor so
the Quran is confirming what is already
with them which is why they should they
should already believe in Muhammad as
well they shouldn't reject him because
he confirms what they
have now you see confirmation means that
he came to confirm to the people and
tell them that there was a Torah there
is in you see that is why the Quran says
those times the people should should um
judge by theil judged by the Torah but
where is it now it says it's with them
is with them where is it have you ever
seen it have you ever heard of it of
course of course
yes so see since the Quran says in
Muhammad's time that it's with them
right it's with the Jews it's with the
Christians well in the seventh century
the Torah they were using was Genesis
Exodus Leviticus Numbers Deuteronomy the
gospel that they
Matthew they had it but they changed the
word of God as now I'm talking to you
let me finish Allah says in the Quran
chapter 2 verse 79
there are people who write books because
if you read in the canonical Bibles and
if you read in the canonical Bibles that
I did not come with it on on on the
table they burned the
Torah they they burned the Torah they
misled that is why Jesus is telling you
even in this Bible of yours now you're
talking about people are saying is you
said in the Bible they Bann the
Torah yes what what Bible is that what
Bible is that yeah it's a little bit far
the canonical Bible theonomic they call
it the the AO the AO Bible apoc
apocryphal Bible apocryphal Bible Al so
so it contains the apocryphal books but
it still has the Torah in it yes but
they B the Torah itself no it's it's
still in that Bible it's still in the
book they banned
it what what do you mean by they banned
it the Torah was already banned that is
why Allah subhah wa ta'ala is
saying is saying in the Holy Quran let
me read for you chapter 3 verse when
they came to Muhammad as you have come
to me now there are some Jews that came
to Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam they were telling them telling
Muhammad sallahu alaihi wasallam to
produce
they wanted him to to to to there was a
problem between the Jews so they came to
the Muhammad and said can you
judge verily those who disbelieved and
died uh chapter 3:
92 chapter 19 verse
19 uh it says verily those who
disbelieve the after their belief and
then went on increasing in their
disbelief chapter
3:90
yeah they came to Muhammad s alaihi
wasallam talking to them about Jacob
when Jacob
had said that I'll not I'll not eat the
coming he is the one who said by himself
not a revelation from God so they said
all food was lawful to the children of
Israel except what Israel made unlawful
for
himself before the Torah was revealed
say oh Muhammad bring here the Torah and
recite it if you are truthful so go
Muhammad sallahu alaihi wasallam is
telling the Jews in that Century he's
telling the Jews if you are truthful if
you are truth
bring the Torah here yes so they not
they didn't have they had already banned
it no they did have it so like so so you
shake just if I can say this really
quick I I love the example that you
brought up about how the Jews came to
Muhammad for a judgment I remember
there's another story like this where um
some people had committed adultery among
the Jews and they came to Muhammad right
for judgment and remember uh if you're
familiar with the story where Muhammad
told them bring the Torah right he said
bring the Torah and when they brought it
they did they had it and they brought it
but one of the Jews was trying to cover
the verse with his yeah yeah they did is
the same brother it's
it's hold on let me let me quot theith
brother if I can so it's it's Sun Abu da
4449 Abu 4449 that's the context behind
Sida vers 43 if you look at if you look
at serida verse 43 it it says why do
they come to you this is Allah speaking
to Muhammad why do they come to you for
judgment while they have the Torah in
which Allah's judgments are in so Allah
says that they have the Torah you know
so if if Muslims are telling us that no
they didn't have it or it was banned why
is Allah saying that they have it my
brother you know when you when you want
to read something you have to read about
the context for example you had
$100 and then you came to
me you asked
me I don't know what you did with your
$100 but you had a problem you needed
$100 but you couldn't make that $100 to
what you wanted and then you from
America comes to me and tells me
shck I want $100 from
you can you help me and then my friend
says he had
$100 why does he come to
you it
means he is giving me a light that
automatically you had
what I have I have the $100 presently so
I don't need your
$100 no you have already used no boom
you have already used the
$100 oh but the verse doesn't say they
already
I'm giving I'm coming to that example
and then you come to me and then I tell
you you have the $100 why do you need
another
one right it is you to explain that I
don't have the $100
right well I I think I think with came
to the prophet I think this example it
would be me having the
$100 they came to the prophet mhm they
had the
Torah yes the prophet said if you are
truthful bring what the Torah the Torah
then God
says why should they come to you and
they have what they have the
Torah you understand me but for them
surely they don't do what they don't
believe
could have brought it no just a minute
this is what they did to Jesus himself
even if you read in the Bible you
remember the alarus woman in the Book of
John 8
verse1 yeah yeah the Jews brought a
woman to Jesus in The Book of John
8:1 they said this woman has committed
alry and the laws of Moses say that this
woman should be put to death right
well actually they were going against
the law because they only brought the
woman it says that the man and the woman
are supposed to be stoned put to death
together how many both of them according
to the Torah yes Jesus bent down because
in the Book of Matthew 5:17 Jesus says I
did not come here to abolish the Torah I
came to fulfill it that's right Jesus
knelt down and he wrote his fingers what
did he write in his fingers the Bible
doesn't say the Bible doesn't
say secondly Jesus turned to the people
who brought the woman and he said if
anyone of you who has no sinen she'll be
the first one to do what to Stone her to
death why did he say
so if you don't know tell me I don't
know um to to show that they can't have
no right to condemn her especially into
and they catch them out because they're
doing the wrong thing I I don't see how
this relates to how the Jews had the
Torah no just a minute okay in the book
of Deuteronomy
17:7 in the laws of
Moses this is what they say that it is
the Torah the Torah was one book but in
here we have five books PQ
books single book when was the Torah a
single book that didn't contain Genesis
Exodus numbers of
Deuteronomy who put down the Genesis and
exodus and numbers and Deuteronomy Moses
Moses and
Joshua so it is Moses who also wrote the
Deuteronomy yeah Moses wrote part of
Deuteronomy Joshua finished it Moses
wrote Joshua finished it m can we read
the book of Deuteronomy
35 I mean 34
35 okay you have the Bible there no all
right you can download what I was
saying I still don't I still don't see
how this is I still don't see how this
is relating to just a second please
okay go ahead thank you yeah so I I
still don't see how this relates to how
Allah says in Muhammad's time that they
have the Torah with
them know you know what we what we doing
is we have to
to to bring things together as you said
if you bring the IB Ma and you bring
there is
also we have another book we have the
abari we have the sah Muslim
which I don't have the full I only have
half of it you see I left the books
there so at least Mr IR you can make a
time and then we speak about it because
the
Torah the Torah is not there and uh you
can come our life uh we'll be having a
debate with the
Christians here
inam and will be on live on all uh
social
networks the Christians and whatever we
have here this will be the debate it
will be here it will be this is
evangelist Daniel he's one he's a very
leared man H is in Dar Salam I'm in
daram in Tanzania it will be on 14th it
will talk about the Divinity of Jesus
and then on 15th on Sunday we'll talk
about the Quran and the Bible which is
the word of God
and it will here venue will be BBT Road
peacock International Hotel Hall yeah
entry is free time will be 900 a.m. to
5:00
p.m. we'll also let you ask the
questions all the books will be there
things will be great so man and I can
see but I don't know if you are tell him
to follow back uh if you can follow back
and then we can be discuss discuss
yes I'm I'm I'm following you now shake
so how how do I um how can I reach you
directly so that we can talk
again this I'll just give you the number
now
no can you come into the into the Inbox
and you communicate the p man now can I
ask you a question you ask do you
believe in Jesus of course who is Jesus
to you he is the divine Son of God who
gave his life for me the Divine you know
if you say Divine means he's more than
human yes I believe he's both human and
divine at the same time he's the Divine
Son of God who took on flesh at a point
in time so he's also God yes and he's
again Son of God yeah being being the
Son of God in Jesus's case is being
sharing the same nature as the
father same nature as the the father so
Natures that the father has is the
natures that Jesus have yes he has the
same nature as the father but then he
also took on a human nature which is why
we say Jesus has two Natures a divine
nature and a human nature all right
today you've taught me something great I
didn't know
come it taught me something great which
I didn't know because when I read the
Bible I don't see about it well next
time next time we talk we can go over
that I love to yeah because I don't want
to speak now let me just ask a simple
question you remember Herod Herod yes
when
[Music]
Herod was the king of the time of the
birth of Jesus you remember yes and then
we have Joseph and then we have Mary
Mary is the mother of Joseph of of Jesus
right that's
right and as the Bible says Joseph was
supposed to marry Mary right yes so the
so Joseph had a
dream God telling him take the son from
Egypt to from Egypt from Israel to Egypt
because Herod wanted to kill the son
right yep the Dream came from
who it came from the angel angel
Gabriel from who the angel Gabriel
yes from God
oh well yeah you know technically yeah
you know God sent Gabriel God gave
Joseph a dream that he should take the
child
right which child was Joseph to take and
which
God revealed to came in the dream of
Joseph which God said that this son who
is he well there's there's only one God
but if you're asking about which person
which person of the God Hand
the father it's the father who sent the
angel to war another question it makes
me
wonder wait did you did you hear my
answer I said so I said specifically the
person of the father of the godhead he's
the one who sent the angel to warn
Joseph all right we'll talk about it no
problem for God so love the world that
he brought his only begotten son that
whoever Shall Believe in him shall not
perish right that's right so God sent a
son God sent a son so that we live in
son we should not perish right that's
right amen which God sent which son was
sent by God and who is this God that
sent the son see this this is
where father just come in the inbox
we'll talk The person the person of the
father sent the son yeah there's no
problem with
that logic we'll come and see how log
yes come come to the to the inbox and
communicate to the PA so that you get
the number there when we will arrange
the time a good debate with you thank
you not a good debate a good discussion
here we not debating we making
discussions and
Islam Allah subhah wa tala says that you
should uh Allah says
in that
is verse 108
Allah says don't insult those ones who
are not Muslims secondly Allah subhah
waala says in the Holy Quran chapter 16
that isah verse6 25 Allah says you make
discussions with the Muslim the
Christians in a good manner in a humble
manner not in in in abusing people so we
have to use wisdom that is hikma and in
good manner thank you very much may God
bless you thank thanks for having me
guys my
[Music]